c'était dans l'air depuis un moment la
décision est désormais officiel la
maison blanche a annoncé que les
etats-unis allaient boycotter les jeux
olympiques d'hiver organisés à pékin au
mois de février 2022 aucun diplomate
américain ne se rendra sur place alors
que les athlètes eux ont évidemment le
droit de concourir le motif invoqué par
la maison blanche la question à des
droits de l'homme en chine et le
gouvernement buydens n'en verra aucune
délégation diplomatique ou officielle
aux jeux olympiques et paralympiques
d'hiver de 2022 à pékin en raison du
génocide et des crimes contre l'humanité
en cours aussi chang et les autres
violations des droits de l'homme
perpétrées par la république populaire
de chine les athlètes de l'équipe
américaine ont notre soutien total nous
les soutiendrons à 100% en les
encourageant de chez nous mais nous ne
contribueront pas à la fanfare des jeux
alors l'éventualité de ce boycott était
annoncé depuis quelques temps par les
médias américains après notamment la
rencontre virtuelle entre joe biden et
jingping cela illustre que les tensions
sont toujours très vive entre pékin et
washington d'ailleurs la décision de la
maison blanche est assez largement
validées par les parlementaires aux
états unis que ce soit les démocrates ou
les républicains qui pour certains
d'entre eux demandent et même à ce que
les athlètes ne participa à la
compétition alors avant l annonce
officielle de la part de la maison
blanche la diplomatie chinoise avait
qualifié l'éventualité de ce boycott
comme démagogique et comme une
provocation politique qui pourrait
conduire à des mesures chinoises en
réponse à cette décision américaine